eddie mcdaniel got one that was kind of
given to her
i sincerely hope i shall always be a
credit to my race
and to the motion picture industry my
heart is too full
to tell you just how i feel and may i
say thank you
god bless you yes well she
she won that i mean and that's the you
know that's another conversation of
you know people talk about well why are
you why are you
uh a proponent of of gone with the
winners
she won an oscar she won an oscar and
broke
everybody's face they put her in the
corner
they put baby
is that what we call is that we're
calling a patrick swayze call back thank
you
see i'm keeping up i'm trying to keep up
with you and the oscar goes to
whoopi goldberg
that moment of going on stage walking up
those steps what was that like what's
going through your head walking down
that aisle to go up those steps
i thought okay finally
[Laughter]
finally i wanted this i wanted it
you know and and people say well you
know it's a comedy it's
probably not going to work and and i
thought about all uh
all the people who didn't get it and i
thought well
i got it i got this this is mine and
and that is also forever
that's part of my moniker academy award
winner
yep you know i like that ever since i
was a little kid
i wanted this you don't know
my brother's sitting there he says thank
god we don't have to listen
anymore you can do it now
my mom's home everybody's watching
what's more fun
watching the oscars at home or being
there on the floor on the stage
oh well now that i'm an old broad i'd
certainly be in there it's more fun my
daughter and i
went a couple years ago because i think
i was
presenting something i don't know why i
was there oh i do know
it was uh because chris rock was doing
he was hosting it which time was it was
it when he did he went to the maggie
johnson theater which is maybe one of
the greatest moments in oscar's history
so i left the kodak theater and went
down to the magic johnson theater
did you see million dollar baby no i
sure didn't i can't lie and i'm not
gonna front to these people out here and
tell you yeah i've seen it
and he was just like listen
you gotta put us in some [ __ ]
you don't have to we don't have to do
everything but now you gotta do it
cause now people calling you out about
it man i counted at least 15 black
people on that montage
and and he's gone through that thing too
where people say things about the show
and then a few years later go oh
he was really good at it is that part of
of the the
thing that comes with it that people
can't recognize what it is you're doing
when you're hosting the oscars at night
because of the expectations
that people in that way you're talking
about people need distance to sort of
judge you
as an oscar's host i think so
i think so you know and they're judging
what you're doing without really sort of
paying attention to what you're doing
it's like
the you know coming out as elizabeth
good evening loyal subjects i
am the african queen
it felt like there were 500 000
elizabeth movies
and betty davis did the greatest i mean
i'm sorry she did the greatest
uh elizabeth movie ever it was within
essex yeah yeah
yeah that's who i patterned that
visual on